et que ce qui s'est passé alors c'est
quoi l'affaire mais je vais vous étonner
je vais pas vous répondre je suis venue
pour ne pas vous répondre merci d'avoir
été là
alors je suis venu pour vous expliquer
que dans le système actuel quand une
personne est accusée par une plaignante
c'est perdant perdant soit
il répond et à ce moment-là il va pas
répondre au juge et ça va être
préjudiciable pour lui parce que la
justice va lui en tirer soit il vient et
puis il répond et il se retrouve dans
une émission de divertissement c'est pas
sa place et on sait pas la place des
personnes mises en cause et des
plaignants de venir
vous dites n'importe quoi déjà pour
commencer c'est un magazine
sur votre plateau il y a une personne
qui est obligée de préciser qu'on ne
peut pas applaudir pour ce type de
sujets des émissions on rigole après il
y a des débats et puis plein de gens qui
viennent tout à l'heure on va pas
rigoler sur l'agression de la vieille
dame donc là déjà vous arrivez vous
dites n'importe quoi faut travailler
avant de venir dans une émission pas
forcément à rire
précisément le principe en fait de la
maintenance c'est de venir vous dire non
pas les mains dans les poches mais avec
des papiers sous les yeux que si vous
mettez en débat la culpabilité d'un
homme avant même qu'il y a une enquête
sur ça on peut faire quels sont les
filles ce qui lui est reproché en fait
c'est tout n'est pas là pour faire un
débat ce qu'il est coupable ou pas
coupable on n'est pas dans sa tribunal
ici et pourtant c'est bien tout ce que
tout le monde
dans les médias oui mais alors mais les
médias c'est les médias nous c'est nous
vous n'êtes pas un média si mais on n'a
rien à voir chacun traite les sujets
comme ils veulent comme voilà
c'est traité c'est traité sur BFM voilà
avec une certaine version sur cnews sur
un TPMP sur quotidien sur c'est à vous
mais c'est rien
pour vous dire que justement quand
l'actualité médiatique très aujourd'hui
d'une affaire judiciaire on est passé
d'une aire où on entendait pas la parole
des femmes ou dès que la parole des
femmes est portée il faut porter la
culpabilité de l'homme il faut tout de
suite venir condamner la personne et moi
simplement ce que j'ai envie de dire
aujourd'hui c'est que plus on est exposé
médiatiquement c'est le cas de mon
client qui est une personne relativement
médiatique et exposée plus on exposait
plus on est fragilisé et je tiens
simplement à dire que si c'était votre
père votre frère ou votre fils vous
auriez peut-être à coeur voté les
spectateurs de voir
l'effet non pas mis en pâture surtout
les Twitter surtout les journaux surtout
les plateaux et débattre en votant pour
oui ou contre
vous faites là vous faites en train de
faire le procès d'une émission donc je
vois pas de parler on n'a pas dit oui ou
non
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé c'est
pas du tout accusé à toi quels sont les
avions contradictions on ne dit pas que
ici vous êtes continue accusé monsieur
Durpaire qui par ailleurs beaucoup
d'amitié pour cette émission je dis que
c'est un système aujourd'hui qui met en
place par l'exposition médiatique
terrifiante la culpabilité d'un homme
sans qu'on lui laisse ni la possibilité
de vous être là madame moi je suis un
peu de savoir et oui pas être là il y a
5 ans il y a 10 ans je ne serai pas venu
je suis venu parce que si aujourd'hui je
ne parle pas on laisse parler et à ce
moment là il est condamné
d'avancement intéressant sans doute
c'est l'histoire de la transaction
financière non mais avant de rentrer
là-dedans on aimerait l'été spectateurs
on va savoir ce qui s'est passé oui
c'est quoi l'histoire donc en 2011
François Durpaire qui entretient en plus
entretient une liaison avec une jeune
femme la reçoit chez lui dans le 11e
arrondissement de Paris à son domicile
et selon elle selon cette plaignante à
ce moment-là il y a un viol mais c'est
l'ensemble depuis longtemps il s'était
une relation qu'ils entretenaient oui
ils étaient ensemble voilà c'était une
ex elle vient apparemment à ce moment-là
pour régler la fin de l'histoire elle
vient discuter comprendre ce qui s'est
passé ensuite elle va dire qu'il y a eu
viol mais des années après de 2011 à
2020 il se passe rien il ne se passe
rien du tout en 2020 il y aura une
transaction financière Jean-Paul
conditionnelle il y aura une transaction
financière de 60 000 euros donc 5000
versets immédiatement pour le silence
réciproque et puis là cette jeune femme
a porté plainte et Monsieur durèrent a
été mis en examen pour viol est-ce que
les fêtes elles qu'ils sont présentées
correspondent à votre réalité à vous
c'est fait tel qu'ils ont été présentés
ils ont été confirmés par le parquet
d'accord moi je suis dans mon rôle à
vous les confirmer aujourd'hui ici
simplement le problème c'est que je dois
venir porter la parole de mon client ici
devant vous puisque vous m'invitez puis
que je veux pas qu'ensuite on vient de
dire bah oui mais quand on l'invite il
se défend pas bien sûr sauf que je ne
peux pas moi venir vous donner des
éléments qui sont couverts par le secret
de l'instruction je peux pas vous donner
tous les éléments à des charges c'est
pour ça que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est per regardant non pas
parce que j'avais pas travaillé mon
dossier mais parce que je vous dis qu'en
fait je viens ici mais bâillonner c'est
un peu comme quand on a mis l'avocat on
garde à vue il a aucun pouvoir il sert à
rien et puis après quand les gens disent
mais oui mais j'ai pas dit ça on dit bah
oui mais vous aviez votre avocat c'est
exactement la même chose que vous pouvez
nous dire ce que vous pouvez nous dire
sur la ferme alors voilà en quelques
mots et ben la faire telle qu'elle
concerne mon client aujourd'hui c'est
une affaire dans laquelle il est mis en
examen certes la mise en examen ça veut
dire quoi très précisément ça veut dire
des indices grave ou concordants c'est
tout ça veut dire aussi que normalement
quand on est un peu inquiet quand on
considère qu'il y a des risques que la
personne s'enfuit ou que elles viennent
atteindre à la plaignante ou aux témoin
on prend un contrôle judiciaire un peu
strict un peu sévère avec des
obligations et puis quand on a qu'on
s'enfuit par exemple
on peut demander un cautionnement c'est
le cas du parquet dans cette affaire qui
avait demandé 10000 euros de caution et
bien dans cette affaire là les juges
d'instruction elles sont deux ont décidé
de ne prévoir aucune de ces obligations
ça part l'interdiction d'entrer en
contact qui est classique il n'a
strictement aucune interdiction de
territoire etc donc il y a quand même
des éléments dont je peux attester
puisque j'y étais qui laisse penser que
voilà c'est une enquête c'est le début
c'est une affaire qui date de 2011 c'est
une affaire qui date de 2011 en tout cas
les faits une transaction financière de
60 000 € comme 18 puisque c'est le
parquet voilà effectivement à énoncé
après de transactions financière à
tentative d'extorsion parfois
l'actualité peut vous montrer
actuellement qu'on est sur sur des
choses qui sont parfois
ça veut dire que vous allez vous mettre
en avant une éventuelle tentative
d'extorsion de votre client en tout cas
je pose je pose la question au débat
j'essaye d'ouvrir les choses on vous
donne des éléments malheureusement le
parquet sélectionne la défense est né au
secret de l'instruction je vous demande
simplement de vous poser la question de
savoir si parfois quand on reçoit de
l'argent c'est pas forcément parce qu'on
vous a imposé de le recevoir mais
peut-être parce que vous l'avez demandé
voilà vous voyez que ça se termine bien
entre nous